let me try and get your head in the
right space for this okay what stuff
have we already done under this topic of
inequalities because you did this before
the exam and you've got some questions
you know what kinds of questions you
have an apology okay
absolute value so maybe something like
this something like that you have to
solve that ok did you do Regents did
your Regents stuff like that yeah now to
be fair this was all I wonder if you
remember me telling you this before the
exam all of this stuff you have covered
by in nine and ten sort of time and
that's really just a warm-up for this
which is the real topic interesting lit
up this the real topic is itself a
warm-up for induction next year not to
be confused with induction cooking but
that's what we're doing okay so not
gonna take too long
but the idea is simply how to deal with
inequalities and prove things to do so
I'll I'll deal with it right off the bat
there are specific kinds of inequality
proofs corn affectionately the am GM
proofs they stand for arithmetic mean
and geometric mean okay now I'm just
going to tell you what they are I'm
gonna tell you they're a four unit topic
eventually we will meet them and I'll
explain them okay but you don't have to
deal with these kinds of proofs under
this topic okay so to answer your
question though you won't need any
serious stuff
okay so just to warm you up a little bit
let's start by thinking what kinds of
things can we apply the logic of
inequalities to that you guys already
know so start with something really
really easy okay and by the way I'm
getting these from a I'm getting these
from a shape that I will give you
shortly but I don't want to give you all
of the [ __ ] just yet which is why I had
it handed to you and let you read along
with me okay so to start with suppose I
tell you this sorry I should just stand
on quiet I'm gonna give you four numbers
and let's uh let's say all of the
numbers are real okay now you will have
to brush up a little bit on your set
notation because I know how much you
love it right
so you set notation if I want four
numbers and I want them all to be real
I'm gonna write it like this hey we see
there are all elements of that's what
the funny a means of the real numbers
here okay so the are with the right now
given that and also given these
relationships so I'm going to give you
the T one two three relationships okay
now the important thing about having
them as real numbers is real numbers can
be ordered okay because there's only one
quantity so you can in a real way you
can say what's bigger than another as
opposed to say complex numbers which
you've been introduced to before
interview work with them right it's like
if I gave you these two numbers which
are complex and nice to you well which
one is bigger you can't really say one
is bigger than another okay they exist
in two dimensions there's a real part
real dimension and an imaginary part
it's like what which one counts for more
well neither of them can be really
compared to each other okay so it's like
saying you know in a field of two
dimensions
say which position is the biggest
positions position real numbers on the
other hand they exist on number one okay
not on a another plane okay so therefore
we want to be able to put these is some
kind of order so here's what I'm gonna
do
I'll give you a minute to give this a go
on your own how would you go about
working out what their order is if you
like at the answer don't spoil it for
everyone but I'll show you not just what
the order is about how it actually set
out how I did this okay so what do you
ever think give it a go I'll come back
together to make out of it 30 in 60
seconds let's go ascending so smallest
to largest what's probably the easiest
way to go about this yeah okay so these
these inequality I was good I'm trying
desperately to avoid saying it because
inequalities as opposed to equality is
right they do actually have a direction
you know it's this way or that way so it
makes us to get them all in the same
direction
okay so let's let's get them from
smallest to think it's kind of steal I
want them in right so I'm gonna flip
these around this one's already in the
right direction
okay and I'll flip these around okay and
now that I've got them all facing the
same way now I can see some other
relationships yeah so for instance a
smaller Dean and be smaller than a right
so if I take these two together clearly
B is the smallest out of all three of
these numbers man be smaller than a
which is what we did
okay
so I can write that in right I can say
what I just established B has to be
smaller than a and a is gonna be smaller
than D right and then this first
inequality I've got means that C will be
the largest of all the phones right so
now you can see I've got them all in
order so therefore I could say from
smallest to largest I've already I've
already written a wall out okay no
problem right
that's right over to this okay one more
you're gonna see the whole topic of
inequalities is kind of like perms and
columns in that it just requires thought
it's not just all you go through a
formula and tada
after my three steps I get an answer
okay you have to engage with it and
think about and use some logic okay so
here we go x y&z all real numbers and
then X is bigger Y and they're both
positive and I know that Z is positive
so I also could have said that um
they're all part of the positive real
numbers okay all right now therefore I'm
trying to fill in some gaps okay I'm
trying to work out what's the
relationship yeah so if I know X is B
good Y then what's gonna happen about
between X plus Z and white clusters
which way is the inequality going to go
or is there an equation
it's positive so it's gonna be it's
gonna be headed in the same direction
right if you like I can think of this as
taking my body here and adding zip to
both sides okay so the direction of the
inequality is the same yeah because
these are questions underneath question
two
because I'm skipping big I just told you
it's on the sheet and I'm skipping pay
attention Wow how are you been sitting
on that one for
I've been waiting months to pull that no
you're not missing okay x squared I
swear if I square both of them both of
them starting from this inequality what
would you expect to happen the direction
the inequality is going to remain the
same right okay but when you divide by H
now again your budget kicks in right if
I'm taking it up and I'm dividing it by
the unabomber and this is the smaller
number right small sorry small
denominator big denominator which ones
bigger one of Y is bigger right
so that's changed the direction equality
so this is still pretty you know pretty
straightforward but you started think
about it okay
all right let me give you some which are
a little more rigorous hmm are you ready
for this one yeah real numbers and
they're all positive
no way no I'm just gonna leave that I'm
just going to leave it now I'm going to
give you much like here I'm gonna give
you three relationships and I want you
to again and put them in order
okay this one's gonna be a lot trickier
so
hey it's gonna be okay we'll get into a
modification soon okay I've got this
relationship and I've got this
relationship now right away
well yes right how does this guy
interact with the others now oh and let
you ever think about it first okay this
one is harder okay but I'll give you
clues you look at this one you like her
that's weird
all these inner qualities I get how I
can put me two qualities together how
they were they how do I get in equality
so mixed with inequalities my tip is you
already have been be seen before they
spin their clinical it's the question is
how so I'll give you a minute to come up
with that and see what you come up with
now here's the problem most people have
they don't know how to get the equation
into it they understand what it mean
that I can't factor it into the rest of
it so here's the crucial thing you need
to get you've been working with
equations and inequalities together
already we did it right here did you
notice that how did I get from this
inequality let's just forget this part
for a minute how did I get from that one
to this one where everyone says Oh duh
you adds it to both sides but there's
another way of thinking about it right I
could instead say well exam that's equal
to said right and so what I do is I add
these inequality right I add it to this
one right because I can I'm adding the
same thing to both sides so if these two
things I can add birth to the same thing
about side right so if I call this one
call this two it might be easier to put
the C
lead on this side and A's and B's on
this side okay now watch let's uh let's
add in first what happens when you add
them okay the DS will cancel yes so I'm
going to get to see the direction of the
inequality stays the same so I'm just
adding the same thing to both sides
right I said the DS cancel same thing
happens here that a is cancel and I get
chibis right so so fast C is less than
me
good how am I going to do something with
the other pair of it is the a and the
date well instead of adding I'll
subtract right okay what's gonna happen
here you're gonna get the seeds will
cancel this time I'm gonna get minus 2 D
less than minus 2 hey yes now that's a
bit that's not so helpful to me I just
want the letters to go through by minus
2 which changes the direction of the
inequality right and I want it from
smallest to biggest right so I'll put
that in the right order and I already
know this that means B is right okay so
now I've got my order C is X to B which
is nested
that span deep-set order is C B